- I think so many people
are keyboard activists.
Everybody's good at sending
a tweet about how the world
should be and nobody's
doing anything about it.
And that is just very much human nature.
So if you're not complaining,
well then I have no advice for you.
I'm pumped, you did it.
You're in control.
Don't complain about it,
you've made that choice.
Don't bullshit me.
I don't wanna be exposed by myself.
It's looking yourself in
the mirror and saying,
"Am I doing this right?"
So, to me, there's so many people
that are talking shit about
how big of an entrepreneur
they're gonna be and how
much they're gonna achieve
and they don't work on weekends.
I worked every Saturday of my 20s.
I planned to instill
kindness into my kids.
I plan on instilling
perspective into my kids.
I plan in instilling just
being a good human being.
I plan on making sure they
don't use their parent's wealth
and microfame and leverage to
impose on any other person.
I'm petrified of that.
If my kids try to punk
their friends on my shit,
I'm gonna beat the fuck out of them.
That's just loser DNA.
You didn't do that.
I just want them to be all-in on them.
I don't need them to be an entrepreneur.
I don't need them to make me proud.
They don't need to go to Harvard.
They don't need to do shit.
They need to be themselves, all-in,
and they need to be kind, and I'm good.
- Do you feel like you judge yourself?
- I don't.
That's a very, very, very good observation
and it's what I want for everybody else.
We're beating ourselves up.
Everybody sucks
at something.
We all have shortcomings.
And we all have strengths.
And for me it's like, why
don't we just audit that?
Why don't we just look at it that way
and be like, alright,
well I'm good at this,
but I'm not good at that.
And then I only focus what I'm good at.
I don't dwell that I can't
fix shit around the house.
I call somebody to fix it.
I'm not like, I'm not a man.
I don't give a fuck.
Your exactly right, man,
I don't judge myself.
I'm fully in love with myself.
But I'm also fully in love
with everybody else, too.
It's not like, it goes both ways.
I tell people to buy into
me, that work for me,
it's 'cause I buy into them first.
Everybody makes these
big deals out of things
that just don't matter.
It's perspective.
My selfishness comes from my selflessness.
It's what makes me feel good,
I say to my mother.
My mom is the epicenter to
every single person in her life.
To me, everything's about breathing.
To me everything is about,
take full ownership for everything
and then everything gets easy.
'Cause then you're in control.
And then learn how to love to lose.
For me, my game's simple.
It's all my fault!
So now, I'm not mad at Lindsay or DRock,
that's it, my fault.
I'm empowering them.
So it's actually true, my fault.
Now, oh, we lost this,
or this didn't deliver,
or we fucked up.
Alright.
So, yeah, all on me.
I enjoy loses.
Now all of a sudden, you
become completely invincible.
I feel invisible.
I really, genuinely outside
of the health of myself
and 20 people feel 100%
invisible as a person.
I know what my intent is.
I wanna do good at nobody else's expense.
I'm far from perfect, we all are.
It's just easy, it feels
very light to live life.
I'm just in a good mood.
I've been trying to forget,
why does this thing even exist?
It's actually the most common
sense thing of all time.
Why is karma seem weird?
The fuck is karma?
Wait a minute, so you're telling me,
if you do lots of good things,
that weirdly good things happened to you?
Yeah, that seems like common sense.
(audience laughing)
I always say, if you wanna be an anomaly,
you have to act like one.
People want all these
special things to happen,
but then they're acting
like everybody else.
I...
Want to do the following,
I'm fascinated by the
same thing that attracts
so many of millions of people,
to people that are selling bullshit.
Those same people are attracted to me.
And what I want to do is suffocate out
all those other people
and become the alpha of
that entire world of people
that are hoping and are desperate
to look at me.
And what I wanna do is
inspire two 14-year-old girls
in Kansas City right now,
to build a billion
dollar company on having
a bunch of employees hugging
each other in the halls.
I want my pedestal moment.
I wanna become that big.
And what I want to come
from that is that kids
that aren't even born today think
that they can build a
five billon dollar company
and be a great guy or great gal.
I want to build the biggest
building in town, ever,
by just building the
biggest building in town.
While I think most people
try to tear down
everybody else's building.
So, I think positivity
and good is practical advice
to building an empire.
And I wanna be the poster
child of the person
that built the biggest, baddest empire
and did it by being a
good dude along the way.
I wanna do it and I wanna be a rockstar.
And that's where you influence people.
I wanna do it, but I also
wanna be the most popular.
And so then, that person's
like, "Oh, I wanna be him.
"So I guess I'll be nice."
I want to literally
take people who have DNA
that's kind of nice
and make them more nice
because they think
that's how I became big.
So I basically wanna trick
the business world into becoming kinder.
(upbeat music)